Something can't “be on fire”. Fire can
only be on things.
The US Patent Office insisted on proof that
the Ouija board worked before granting the
patent in 1891.
In the Second World War, British troops were
issued with three sheets of toilet paper a
day; American soldiers got 22.
88% of women routinely wear shoes that are
too small for their feet.
Seven US Presidents were born in log cabins.
A 1571 law stated that all Englishmen must
wear knitted hats on Sundays.
There are more marijuana dispensaries in Denver,
Colorado, than there are branches of Starbucks.
Before erasers were invented, breadcrumbs
were used to rub out mistakes.
If you tickle a rat every day, it'll start
laughing as soon as it sees you.
People with higher incomes generally prefer
their loo paper to unravel over the roll,
while those with lower incomes prefer it to
go under.
The opening ceremony of the Beijing Olympics
was the first time a billion people have watched
a sporting event.
Croquet was dropped as an Olympic sport after
1900 because only one spectator turned up
to watch.
It's impossible to set fire to a pool of petrol
by throwing a lit cigarette into it. It's
also really, really unlikely that shooting
the fuel tank of a vehicle will cause it to
explode. It's just not as easy as the movies
make it out to be.
In 2007 Scotland spent £125,000 to develop
a new national slogan. The winning entry was
"Welcome to Scotland".
The Milky Way gives birth to a new star every
50 days.
Everyone has at least 50,000 thoughts a day
but 95% of them are the same as the day before.